[Music]
jess i gotta know
because you you talk about a lot of
relationships in the course of your book
call me sexual napoleon have you heard
from any of your exes
after you shared your truth through open
book no
when i met eric i did change my phone
number email everything like
and the people that do still communicate
with any of my exes they know not to
ever
bring them up it's like a rule
so basically jessica gets the last word
in her incredibly candid best-selling
memoir
open book which is out in paperback
today when i was
writing the memoir i was going through
a time in my life where i gave up
alcohol and so like going through my
journals and
rereading them several of those journal
entries are included in the paperback
release
including this one from 2009 written
just after the mom jeans controversy
you say i beat myself up about how fat i
am
i wear size 25 that's insecurity
i had the weight literally of the world
on me and that feels heavy to button in
you know like you're a mom of two girls
what are you hoping to teach them
about body insecurities well they're
very secure so far
my oldest daughter is so much like my
sister
like unapologetically authentic and
little birdie may she just turn to
he's the most independent of anyone in
this family
any talk between the two of you about
expanding your family oh no
that's not mom jess oh no no
that was the last pregnancy my little
body could endure
you're looking incredible what are some
more secrets
of achieving that post baby weight i say
throw
out the scale because the scale can
literally
like mess our entire day up i
like had eric walk up to the trash can i
have to rid myself
of like measuring up to like
what weight i should be because i've had
so many people tell me what weight i
need to be and
you know it doesn't happen overnight and
you have to be patient with yourself
and nearly 18 years after dominating
reality tv
with newlyweds nick and jessica i know
it's tuna but
it says chicken she's returning to the
unscripted world with a docu-series
jessica signed a huge deal with amazon
to executive produce
two series based on open book they're
gonna do scripted and unscripted
versions
of your book so are you at all nervous
anxious about getting back into
unscripted oh no no no i mean
i've been filming the unscripted is like
i mean i have 10 years of footage in the
script it's fun because
then i can like add characters and play
with it
who's gonna play you though jessica i
think there has to be an
unknown i don't know
all i gotta say is good luck to the
casting directors trying to find someone
just like jessica